- [Narrator] This is Gemma.
Nearly eight feet tall, she
is one big Bactrian camel,
the largest of all living camel species.
Gemma is 15 years old, which
places her at middle age
for Bactrian camels.
Native to the steppes of Central Asia,
Bactrian camels have two humps, not one.
And contrary to what many people think,
their humps contain fat, not water.
They convert the stored fat into energy,
which can be used in
place of water or food.
This, along with their clumpy, wooly coats
and tolerance for high
altitudes, make them the perfect
companions for long, difficult journeys.
Domesticated Bactrian camels are abundant,
but wild ones are critically endangered
due to hunting and loss of habitat.
Over the course of the next couple
of generations, their numbers
outside of domesticity
are expected to dwindle to just a quarter
of its current population.
This is the Bactrian camel.
(digital tone)